AMD just dropped their new Radeon 9000
Series cards and I'm really impressed by
what I'm seeing here with the radon RX
970 XT and the non-xt variant of the 970
from 1440 all the way up to 4K both of
these cards are offering outstanding
performance and I think a lot of people
out there are going to want to get their
hands on them in this video we're going
to be testing out the allnew AMD Radeon
RX 970 XT I've also got the RX 970 non-x
variant and for a couple of these tests
we'll throw the RTX 570 into the mix
just to see how everything Stacks up
against each other it's no secret that
AMD recently announced these cards and
what I've got here is the Asus Prime
overclock edition of the RX 970 XT and
the overclock edition of the 970 non XT
variant I do have more videos planned
there are a couple builds that I want to
do with both of these cards we're going
to go small form factor with some of
them but in this video we're mainly
going to be focusing on the RX 970 XT I
think that's the one that a lot of
people are going to want to get their
hands on taking a look at the Asus Prime
version it is a 2.5 slot card and it
requires three eight pin power
connectors overall I've always loved the
aesthetic of these Asus Prime cards
there's no RGB here and that's something
I've been trying to get rid of on a lot
of my PCS but usually nowadays it's
actually a bit cheaper to go with RGB on
some of the parts so I'm glad to see
that they didn't add any here very clean
aesthetic minimalistic and I think this
can go inside of an all-h chassis or a
black chassis and look just fine full
metal vented back plate plus we've got a
dual bios performance mode or quiet mode
you can swap this out with the switch at
any time dual ball bearing triple fans
and these are asus's new axial tech fans
so they've got the longer blades here
and it's got a zero DB mode so under
light use or just idling these fans will
completely turn off and just to give you
a look here the biggest difference
between the Asus Prime RX 970x and the
non XT variant are the connectors
obviously we've got a higher tgp on the
XT model it's going to pull more wattage
up to 304 Watts with no overclock and it
requires three 8 Pin connectors as
opposed to the 9070 that only requires
two 8 Pin connectors the cards are the
same length they're 2.5 slot and to tell
you the truth I kind of wish the non XT
variant was just a bit shorter than the
XT and of course when it comes to the
overall specs of the XT version we've
got 16 GB of gddr6 running at a 256-bit
bus 64 MB of AMD Infinity cache 64
compute units 4,096 stream processors
total board power is 304 wats without an
overclock and they do recommend at least
a 650 W power supply in order to get all
of the testing done with this card and
the others they're all going to be
inside of the same rig what I've got
here is an i 714 700k 360 mm aiio 32
gigs of Viper Ram running at 7400 MHz
and for the power supply I've got an
Asus Prime 850 watt and again keep an
eye on the channel because I've got a
couple more videos coming up I want to
do a small formfactor build with the XT
or the non XT let me know what you'd
like to see in the comments below but
we're probably going to end up pairing
this thing up with the AMD ryzen 9800
x3d first thing I want to do here is
jump into some Real World gameplay with
the XT then we're going to move over to
some benchmarks and compare this to the
non-xt variant and even the RTX
570 here we have cyberpunk 2077 4K using
the ultra preset and with some upcoming
benchmarks we're going to go native 4K
but a lot of people are going to run it
out of the box at a preset so I wanted
to show you how it runs we're seeing an
average of 75 FPS with cyberpunk 2077 4K
Ultra preset this is some great
performance at 4 4K I mean it's actually
performing way better than I thought it
would and you could definitely get more
out of it using frame gen if that's what
you want to do but uh overall by itself
like this it's looking
amazing
not I also wanted to run some 3D Mark
benchmarks on the XT and the non-xt
steel noad on the XT we got a total
score of
7,079 around 70 FPS and on the non-xt
variant total score of
5,795 average of50 7 FPS getting close
to 58 and again these are in the same
exact system 14700
K next one we have here is Port Royal on
the XT total score of
18357 FPS of 84 looks great here and
that 970 isn't that far behind total
score
15,27 with an average of 70 FPS and the
final one we have here is time spy and
both of these scores are looking really
good over on the XT our graphic score
was
29,9 184 on the non-xt
2,571 next up we've got some in-game
benchmarks and I wanted to throw the RTX
570 into the mix cyberpunk 4K native
Ultra as you can see that RTX 570 even
came behind the non-xt variant and with
the XT we had an average of 61 taking it
down to 1440p now our average jumped way
up on the XT version and the 570 is
still falling behind the non XT moving
over to Horizon zero Dawn remastered 4K
native very high XT had an average of 72
FPS and the non-xt did fall behind the
570 in this test at 4K and even
1440 but the XT is still holding strong
here up to an average of 134 FPS and the
final one I tested was black myth wo
Kong 4K native cinematic if you've ever
tried to run this at cinematic on any
system you know how hardcore it is the
XT managed 30 FPS the non-xt 24 and you
can see that the RTX 570 came in at 13
FPS and this really comes down to the
vram amount we've got 16 gigs of vram
with both of the 97s and only 12 gigs
with the 570 and with Wukong set at that
cinematic preset it is running out of
vram 1440 same settings here on the XT
we had an average of 50 non XT 41 and on
the 570 we were up to 29
FPS now it's time to get back into some
more real world gaming with the XT and
right now we've got Spider-Man 2 4K very
high no raay tracing we're not using FSR
we're not using frame generation or
anything like that this is native 4K at
the highest settings minus Ray tracing
now one thing I didn't have access to
because it's not in the games yet is FSR
4 but AMD does claim that the will be a
bunch of games day one once this
launches with FSR 4 support so I will
make another video checking that out I'm
really interested to see what that can
do and how it
looks here's Forza Horizon 5 4K Extreme
Plus and for extreme plus I mean when
you go to the extreme preset there's
actually some settings that still can go
up a bit like raid tracing we're totally
maxed out here at 4K getting an average
of 141 FPS
[Music]
here's Marvel Rivals 4K Ultra preset and
I thought we'd see a little more out of
this but that's kind of how it goes with
this game right now it's still early
access every time I test it on a higher
end card I kind of expect more out of it
but right now we're seeing an average of
around 68 fps to tell you the truth with
most of these Esports games 1440 is
going to be more than enough and at 1440
with these same settings we're getting
an average of
93 Doom Eternal 4K Ultra nightmare raid
tracing off and AMD claims that with
raid tracing on you can see an average
of 144 FPS and it's totally possible
with raid tracing but I left it off here
and by the end I had an average of 21
FPS
yes the final game we have here is
Monster Hunter Wilds 4K Ultra preset and
keep in mind with that Ultra preset FSR
is set to ultra quality so we are using
a little here and we still get those
dips under 60 but one big thing to keep
in mind is at the time of making this
video this game is not very well well
optimized yet we're still waiting on
patches from the developers so it's only
been out for about a week at the time of
making this video so definitely keep
that in mind I got a feeling you know
once we get some more performance
patches for this game we're going to see
better performance at this Ultra preset
but I figured I'd go ahead and take it
down to the high
preset and at that 4K High preset we're
now over 60 seeing an average of 74 FPS
with
so yeah not too bad for 4K a lot of
people are going to be just fine playing
this at 1440p but I really wanted to
kind of stress the XT
out don't mind if I do
last thing I wanted to talk about here
were thermals and with the prime variant
this is actually using a phase change
GPU thermal pad it just creates a nice
even layer between the GPU die and the
cooler itself plus you don't have to
worry about squeeze out and this thing
isn't going to dry out as fast as
thermal compound would and with the
newly designed Prime cards from Asus I
haven't worried about thermals with any
of these cards so far and this one's no
different in the case I'm using side
panel on average 4K gaming 49° C and the
maximum temp this hit was only 66 while
running benchmarks average 4K gaming 46°
C and the maximum this ever hit was 55°
C the triple fans paired up with the
cooler they design and that phase change
thermal pad really do a great job on
this Prime card overall really impressed
with the performance the 9070 XTS put
now in and in my next video we will
explore some overclocking or maybe even
just uh you know some power limit
tweaking just by taking that up a bit we
can reach some pretty high clocks on
this card it's actually really
impressive and with what we have here I
think a lot of people out there are
going to want to jump on board with the
9070 XT given the state of gpus right
now and it's really going to come down
to pricing and unfortunately at the time
of making this video since this is the
prime overclock Edition I don't have the
price on this thing but keep in mind
it's the overclock version which do tend
to run a bit more than MSRP cards AMD
has set the MSRP of the XT at 599 so
overclock cards do run a bit higher
definitely keep that in mind but again
I'll leave the price and a link where
you can buy it in the description as
soon as it's available but until then
I'd love to know your thoughts in the
comments below is the AMD RX 970 XT
offering enough performance for you to
consider picking one of these up are you
going to skip it all together keep what
you have now wait for next gen let me
know down below but that's going to wrap
it up for the this one like always
thanks for watching